yesterday there was word of a new
PlayStation handheld today it's talk
about a Fallout New Vegas 2. both rumors
that won't ever go away until they
become true here's what you need to know
a new Branch titled New Vegas 2 was
added to Fallout 4's backhand and was
made visible to players after an update
on April 4th think of software and game
development like a tree the trunk is the
game itself and developers can create
branches from that trunk to work off of
without tampering with the actual
project or stepping on the work of
another developer since this New Vegas 2
branch is connected to the trunk of
Fallout 4. the speculation is that the
game's Next Gen update that was
announced last fall with an intended
launch sometime this year will feature
new content around New Vegas
specifically content created in creators
Club third party mods initially
developed by fans while the branch has
since been either deleted or properly
hidden from users that hasn't stopped
people online from speculating about a
New Vegas sequel considering that
Microsoft now owns the IP holder Fallout
Bethesda and the developers of the
original New Vegas obsidian the company
has literally all the pieces to make a
New Vegas 2. there's even interest from
involved parties to do so with the head
of obsidian Fergus urkhart telling game
pressure in January quote of course if
we ever got the opportunity to make
another Fallout game we'd make it
fortunately for New Vegas fans erkahart
confirmed in the same interview that
obsidian does not currently have a
Fallout game in development lending
further Credence to the theory that the
mysterious New Vegas 2 branch is
strictly related to an upcoming Fallout
4 update and likely unrelated to a
remake or sequel of obsidian's 2010 RPG
going back to yesterday's PlayStation
handheld rumors which made mention the
device would include controls akin to a
dual sense controller with haptic
feedback and adaptive triggers it seems
the company might take things to a
completely other level with a potential
dual sense 2 with a new patent
application that suggests Sony is
looking to implement temperature
feedback into its controllers the
company has filed a patent application
for a material that can simulate
temperature feedback to its controllers
in order to reflect what is going on
during gameplay the controller would
feature a malleable membrane for its
exterior rather than the hard plastic of
traditional controllers not only could
this membrane change shape based on what
was occurring in the game but an
electrical current could pass through it
in order for the user to feel a
simulated change in temperature this
material would also allow for better
more precise haptic feedback than the
current material of the Dual sense while
this all sounds cool in practice what
I'd rather simply have Sony invent is a
dual sense controller with decent
battery life are you still longing for a
New Vegas to want improvements would you
like to see to the Dual sense controller
let us know in the comments and we'll
see you here for more Gamespot news
thank you